The English Premier
League is widely regarded
as being home to the very
best soccer in the world.
It's a goal!
Stanislas makes it three-three!
It's watched by billions across the globe,
making it the richest too.
And while soccer,
as we Americans call it
isn't one of the top
sports here in the U.S.
it's never seen so many
American investors in the U.K..
Wait!
Even American superheroes are getting
in on the action.
Cue the music.
Could Deadpool and Mac
from 'It's Always Sunny'
really save the day?
US sports teams bring in
a huge amount of money
for their owners.
But if you wanna buy into the NFL
from the Dallas Cowboys to
the lowly Cleveland Browns,
sorry Cleveland,
you probably need to be a
billionaire several times over.
But, for those who love what the rest
of the world calls football,
buying into the English
Premier League is way cheaper
and could give you a much better return.
Aguero!
A billion plus people
interact with the EPL.
When you look at any American sport
there's nothing anywhere close to it.
It just smelled of opportunity to me.
While the huge investment
in the EPL is intrinsically linked
to the high quality of the competition
and its star names, big money talks.
And it doesn't care much
for history or tradition.
As radical plans to transform
the game have been revealed
U.S. investors are increasingly
viewed with suspicion.
But will these changes be
for the good of the game,
or just the wealthy owners?
Takes the snap,
drops back,
pumps once, looks right
throws, endzone!
Jets have the lead,
it's 54, 35.
Dover Athletic nil,
Northwich Victoria nil.
While our sporting sensibilities
might be drastically different,
when it comes to sheer
commercial enterprise,
the English Premier
League is right up there.
The Premier League's
broadcast revenue is more
than four billion dollars a season.
It's way richer than the
other European leagues,
even the ones with global
superstars, like Messi,
Ronaldo and Neymar.
And more of us in the
States are tuning in too,
at the expense of our
own pro soccer league.
More than twice as many
people watch EPL games
than the MLS.
So how did English football
become such a hot deal
for American investors?
I need an Englishman to
help me figure this out.
All right, so Alex, educate me here.
As an American I'm intrigued,
but also a little bit confused, candidly,
by English football.
So, what are the main differences,
especially from the business perspective?
Fundamentally, in the U.S. you
have a league system whereby
there's a defined number
of teams in the league.
Revenues tend to be doled
out a lot more evenly
between those teams.
Obviously if you finish a
little bit higher at the table,
you get a little bit more.
In Europe, particularly in the
U.K. you have a league system
of four professional divisions
and than a number more amateur divisions.
And theoretically, if you or I set up
an amateur team tomorrow, we could,
inside a decade, be playing
in the Premier League.
Obviously in practice
it's a lot more difficult
but by being promoted up the tiers,
we could be a Premier League team.
At 11:30 precisely the game gets underway
with Chelsea attacking.
It's left winger Tommy Knox
working the ball along,
across to Harris, then
to right winger Murray.
Straight into the safe hands of England
and Blackpool goalkeeper, Tony Waiters.
A lot of the history
of these teams is so baked into
the community, maybe
in a way that it isn't
here in the United States.
Yeah, when you look at the
names of teams, actually,
you could see some of that.
Think about a team like Arsenal.
It was actually the team associated
with the Woolwich
Arsenal, a military base,
south of the river in London.
With Aston Villa, that's my team,
it was a cricket team
that met up and said,
We want to stay fit during the winter.
They met outside Aston Villa,
a villa in the Birmingham suburb of Aston,
named their team after it.
This is a massive business.
I mean the reason that this is attracting
so much investment ultimately is
because these team values
have just skyrocketed,
certainly, in the EPL.
Yes and a lot of that has
to do with the success
of cultivating an international audience.
The way that the Premier
League in particular
has really forged a lead
was in a sense by following
what happened in the U.S..
In the early '90s they started
doing collective bargaining
for their broadcasting rights.
It used to be the case that
if you're Manchester United
or Arsenal, or whichever club it might be,
you would individually
negotiate with the broadcaster.
They said, actually, we're
better off as a unit,
if we all negotiate together.
And that's when the
Premier League was formed.
You tie that up with the
arrival of Rupert Murdoch,
trying to bring a satellite
TV station to the U.K..
He recognized there was
a huge amount of passion
for football.
If he could lock up the rights for that,
he would secure an audience
for his pay TV station.
The F.A. Premier League,
live, only on Sky.
Now since the Premier League was formed,
we've seen a huge ballooning
in the value of broadcast rights.
It's jumped 60-fold since 1992.
So previously the value of the rights was
about £600,000 per game.
In the most recent round it
was about 9 million per game.
That is astonishing.
So, with those sorts of figures,
it stands to reason that big
investors in the United States
and elsewhere would come calling
and see a lot of opportunity.
They've seen opportunities for a bargain.
You can buy a middling football club
for several hundred million.
You can buy a football
club in the second tier,
for considerably less than that.
You compare that to the
NFL, where, you know,
franchises change hands for
perhaps two billion dollars.
Huge difference there.
We're not for fucking sale!
The most famous U.S.
owners were the Glazers
who owned the Tampa Bay Bucs.
They came and bought Manchester United.
And they approached it
with the kind of attitude
of a private equity company.
You can pile a huge
amount of debt onto it,
extract some of that as cash
to line your own pockets
and because they are
fundamentally media assets,
it's quite resilient.
As long as they invest
enough in the playing squad,
keep them in the Champions League,
you're going to be able to generate enough
free cashflow to service
your debt obligations.
This is a couple of
thousand quid's worth of
season tickets going up in smoke
The Glazers aren't exactly
loved in Manchester
and to many British fans,
they reflect the confusing
emotions inspired by U.S. ownership.
Incredible financial
growth might also coincide
with declining sporting performance.
If you're looking for a model
of American ownership to follow,
it might just be Man United's
biggest rivals, Liverpool.
The current champions
have enjoyed a resurgence
in recent years.
And that's happened since
they were taken over
by Fenway Sports Group.
Those are the guys behind
the Boston Red Sox.
An ownership group that
knew what success was about,
that knew how to build patiently,
everything that a football club is about.
This is Peter Moore,
he was the CEO of Liverpool
when they won the Champions League in 2019
and then the Premier League in 2020.
So Peter, what did Fenway
bring to Liverpool?
Maybe something specific that they brought
from running a very successful
and very fabled American baseball team.
First thing that struck me when I spoke
with Mike Gordon is, he said,
"We're not the owners
of this football club."
He said, "We have the
economic rights to do business
on behalf of this football club.
The owners are the fans."
For me certainly there
was no true interference
in how we managed the football club.
We improved the structure
of the football club,
they applied science and data.
All of the things that they'd learned
in the days of Theo Epstein
and young general managers.
And brought in actual
scientists and data analysts.
So the thousands of players were analyzed
that were in the marketplace.
And our own players were analyzed
to get the best out of them.
Quick snap, protected in the pocket
the ball comes out!
And the 49ers are on it!
One of the EPL's newest
American execs comes
with a deep knowledge
of American football.
And a business acumen shaped by decades
in and around Silicon Valley.
But he's the first to
admit he's not a soccer fan
from the cradle.
I started looking into
soccer clubs, football clubs
in Europe, gosh, maybe 10 years ago.
At that time, you know,
with all due respect,
I still didn't know if a soccer
ball was puffed or stuffed.
Paraag Marathe is the president
of 49ers Enterprises,
which bought a stake in
Leeds United in 2018.
Part of an ambitious effort by one
of America's story franchises
to expand its portfolio.
At the time Leeds was
itself a fabled franchise.
But one that had fallen on hard times.
Leeds were playing in the second division
of English football.
Last season they won
promotion to the top division,
the EPL.
Premier League here we come!
Come on!
So tell me about promotion
from a business perspective
because you're doing a calculation here
about a huge potential upside.
You're talking about a 20X increase
in per club media rights
from going from the Championship
to the Premier League.
You still play in the same
stadium with the same size.
And you have the same number of fans.
I can count the same number
of suites and premium
but your media rights goes up 20-fold.
Promotion to the Premier League
could be worth anywhere from
130 to 200 million pounds.
Just take this example.
In 2016 another second division team,
Wolverhampton Wanderers, were bought
for around 63 million dollars.
They gained promotion shortly after that
and are now estimated to be worth
around 10 times that figure.
Taking a punt, as they say in England,
on a team rising up the
divisions can really pay off.
But what goes up, can also come down.
A concept we Americans
aren't exactly familiar with.
Two teams here who are
desperate for three points
to avoid relegation.
What are you looking forward to?
Well, I'm looking forward to
the definition of relegation.
Three teams drop out of the Premier League
every season.
Yes, relegation is real and it's kind of,
you have to manage the delicate balance
because there is a correlation
between acquiring more
players in the transfer market
and buying players to be able to,
to be more competitive.
And winning and matriculating
up the table, right?
But at the same time
that comes with a risk
because if you spend a
lot in the transfer market
and you get relegated,
now all of the sudden,
you're potentially more
in a world of hurt.
So yeah, you do have to factor that in
and you do have to model that.
One year ago the club's
valuation was much different
than it is today.
And trying to figure out, okay well,
which one is the real,
sustainable valuation.
Like, that's a hard exercise to do.
I hope for Paraag
and Leeds fans they
don't drop anytime soon.
The history of British
football is littered
with stories of big time clubs going down.
And not making it back.
But for many fans a
relegation battle can be
just as exciting as the
chase for a championship.
It's a very performance-based system
and I'm sure there's
probably some fans that say,
"Wow, I wish we had something
like that in America."
And I'm not suggesting any
owner wants that in America,
don't get me wrong.
Alan Pace and his U.S.
investment firm ALK Capital
have also just joined the Premier League.
They've taken over Burnley,
a team just 50 kilometers away from Leeds
in the north of England.
We talk about performance-based
stuff all the time
in business and as entrepreneurs
and as other things.
Performance-based means you
get rewarded for performance.
It seems kind of odd
that you wouldn't have it
within your own sports process of,
"Look, if you don't perform,
you don't get to stay
with everybody else."
But it's also super interesting
and I think very cool
that people can get promoted
and people can get relegated
based off of performance.
So Alan, as an investor,
what appeals to you
about the EPL?
You have a global audience.
That is very, very different
than any American sport.
I mean, you're talking a
billion plus people interact
with the EPL.
And when you look at any American sport,
there's nothing anywhere close to it.
Now, I'm not suggesting
that you've monetized
that billion plus.
But if you just even
for half a second think
about how could I monetize that situation
from a business perspective,
you've got an audience already.
So, like, how do you bring that capability
and that knowledge from American sports
into an audience that's
just that much bigger.
And, can you?
That is a challenging
question for a lot of people
is can you actually do
something with that?
And honestly, our bet is yes you can.
What I have noticed
about football in Europe
versus, kind of, American
football in college,
it's almost very similar.
That sense of community,
that sense of passion.
Everybody coming together
and really kind of jelling
for something, a big event.
And so, even though we're 30 - 40 minutes
outside of Manchester,
the whole community is a Burnley fan.
This is a relatively small town.
Everybody knows everyone.
And certainly they know
when an American shows up
and buys the team.
What does that feel like for you?
Well, you know, it's funny
because there's a lockdown
and so we haven't really
got to meet a lot of people.
So no one's tried to
burn down my house yet.
And there's been no
pitchforks or anything.
There's no reason to believe
ALK will manage Burnley badly
but it's the kind of leveraged acquisition
that can make fans nervous
and has previously resulted
in major fan protest.
If I were a Burnley fan,
I would be just a little bit
anxious, because you know,
there I was supporting a club
that was earning 100 million a year
from being in the Premier
League, from broadcast income,
had 40 million pounds in the bank,
to a club that now has quite high debt.
They're still in relegation
trouble this season.
They could be in relegation
trouble most seasons.
And if they are relegated,
then obviously their
broadcasting income diminishes
by 20 times.
Burnley could be relegated
and then never come up again
into the Premier League.
There's a definite risk of that.
If you're buying a team
in the Premier League
the value of that team
is very closely tied
to its on-field performance.
And that is just not the case in the U.S..
You're de-risked to a great
degree as a franchise owner
in the States.
Because you know if you have a poor year,
you'll get the top pick of the draft.
That gives you better chances of improving
in subsequent years.
You have one poor year
in the Premier League
and you're down a division
and losing a huge amount of revenue.
Teams adapted differently to relegation.
But some just go straight down.
You know, they just can't cope.
It's like the whole fiber of
the club seems to collapse.
So Alan, I've looked at the message boards
and it's fair to say there's
some skepticism out there.
Especially about the
structure of the deal.
So from a lay person's perspective,
walk me through it.
The best analogy that I would give as
to what we've done is,
think about you've seen a house, OK,
that you really like.
But you think it's probably a little bit
of a fixer-upper.
And you take a mortgage
because it actually makes sense
with the process of what you're doing.
And then, you could use some
of your capital more efficiently
in actually investing into
the club in different ways.
Or fixing up the house in different ways.
Yes, there's leverage.
There's no doubt about it.
Because any of us that
have ever had a home
or that have ever charged
anything on credit,
on a credit card, there's
leverage in our lives.
Now if Burnley's a fixer-upper,
this next club is one of
the most unlikely recipients
of an American makeover.
And we're not talking about
just any U.S. businessmen here.
We're talking about
A-listers, Ryan Reynolds
and Rob McElhenney.
Wrexham are what's known as minnows,
small fish in a big pond.
In normal times they have
an average attendance
of just 5000 fans.
Which is actually pretty good
for a team in the fifth division.
Last season they ranked 111th
in the football pyramid.
So, Wrexham is a long way from
that sweet broadcast revenue.
If you start in the bottom
you've got the amazing upside
of the possibilities of promotion.
Ultimately they, I think, are looking
for a story to be able to tell,
Ryan Reynolds and Rob McElhenney.
It looks like they are seeking
a vehicle for a narrative.
And ideally that narrative is:
Get the team promoted up the divisions.
And that would make for
a pretty compelling show
on Netflix or Amazon Prime
or wherever it might land.
That team has not got a
huge amount of revenue.
Only sort of two or three
million pounds a year.
If you're looking at a Netflix show
which you're selling for
several hundred thousand pounds
an hour and you have an
eight hour mini series,
all of the sudden you've
doubled that team's revenue
in one fell swoop.
It's a sort of active management.
It is very much bringing special sauce
and applying it to the asset.
This isn't a punt either.
In recent years streaming
services have been flooded
with sports documentaries.
For most teams it's a
small part of the business.
For Wrexham, according to a letter sent
to potential sponsors,
it's a key part of the commercial pitch,
along with the opportunity to
get your name on the shirt,
the stadium and working personally
with two interested Hollywood stars.
Sports documentaries cost
less than top level games
and have a longer shelf life.
The biggest problem is
whether it makes compelling television.
Good TV requires troughs as well as peaks.
Meaning losses as well as wins.
Next thing I know Rob
McElhenney gives me a buzz
and says, "I'd love to
pop up to Santa Barbara."
He, like all of us, started
to consume massive amounts
of Netflix during lockdown.
And stumbled across a
documentary series called
"Sunderland 'Til I Die."
And he said, "I watched
this and I was enthralled."
And less with the football
action but the people
and the agony and the angst.
And he said, "I know these people.
This is Philadelphia.
This is every city that
is going on tough times,
that is been let down by the one thing
that can lift the spirits,
which is their team."
As a result he said, "I
called Ryan and said,
'We need to buy a football club.'"
Just like I had to turn to the experts
to really understand
football to begin with,
so too did Ryan and Rob.
See, stars, they're just like us.
And they had the perfect guy.
Someone who'd not only
run a championship club
but who'd actually lived in Wrexham.
Wrexham!
I grew up there, I played football there.
I played for Wrexham School Boys,
played at the Racecourse
Ground where Wrexham play.
So when I wasn't playing
I watched Wrexham.
And in those days they
were a very good team,
playing in the second
division of English football.
'Giant Killers' as it's known.
So the big clubs would come in the FA Cup,
the knock out competition and
most famously beat Arsenal.
Fast forward to, you know,
as recently as a year ago
and the club had fallen
into, quite frankly,
disarray, it'd gone into
administration, bankruptcy.
Nolan.
Well, he's tripped there.
Now the situation
for Wrexham fans was kind of win-win.
They can't fall much
further and in their eyes
American ownership probably
means climbing the ladder
and maybe even hitting the big time.
Oh what a goal!
One of the goals of the season.
But when foreign owners pick up a team,
in part to use it as a
vehicle for a video series,
it gives you a sense of how
much the game has changed.
Football is a very simple virtuous cycle.
You make as much money
as you possibly can,
you invest that on the pitch.
Those players bring you victories.
When you win a lot sponsors like that
and they will give you more money,
which you then turn around
and spend on the pitch
and you get even better players,
who win you league championships
and Champions League trophies.
And sponsors wanna be
a part of that as well.
And they give you even more money.
So it's a classic virtuous cycle.
Ultimately what happens
in the best leagues
in the world won't have that much effect
on the grass roots.
Kids will still go to the park and play
and they'll continue to
play for years to come.
But the question remains,
will big business spoil
the beautiful game?
In recent months a lot
of chatter has emerged
about how the biggest clubs
in the world are trying
to consolidate power
and get a bigger slice of
the pie for themselves.
Which raises another question,
can English football survive
this Americanization?
I think if you went to ask
almost any football fan,
do you like relegation and promotion?
They will say yes, because it is actually
what brings a thrill to the game.
When people talk about
football evoking such passion,
partly because there's
more at state for the club.
You know, if you lose a game,
you could be out of the top
league for a number of years
and in the doldrums.
There's a move to try
to get the top clubs in a league
which is always the same
members year in, year out.
It is a way of ensuring that
those clubs retain their value,
they have predictable revenue
that will be recurring
for the years to come.
And because it's at a European level,
whether we're playing against
all the other top clubs,
they will attract a bigger,
international fan base.
Now that might be to the detriment
of a normal fan, every day
fan, in their home city.
For a simple reason, they may not be able
to travel to Munich or Madrid
or Milan every other week,
it's quite expensive.
And so it's something that investors like
but fans on the whole, really don't.
The biggest fear of course
is that you lose fairytales
like Leicester City.
This is a team that rose
from being in the third tier
of English football to
winning the whole thing
in a span of just seven years.
At 5000-1 to win the league that season,
bookmakers had never paid out so much.
But there are other types of fairytales,
maybe still to be written.
Who knows?
Maybe we'll see Wrexham in the
Premier League before too long.
Thanks so much for watching.
We'd love to hear what
you think about this
and other episodes about
the business of sports.
I'll be in the comment section.
Can't wait to hear what you think.